in this lesson we're going to talk about
the sine and cosine graphs these are
oftentimes referred to as sinusoidal
graphs and they're basically like an s
shape type graph but let's talk about
the basic format of the equation so when
you look at the sine or cosine graph it
basically falls into this format and you
can see the number that's in front of
her to the left of the sine or cosine
that a value that's called the amplitude
that's how high the waves are
from the midline okay and then the b
value here that's used to calculate the
period the periods how long it takes for
the graph to repeat okay or to complete
one cycle and the way you can figure
that out from the equation or from the
formula is by taking 2 pi which is the
normal period divided by this b value
this number that's in front of her to
the left of the x okay and then the h
the number is grouped with the x that
shifts the graph left and right in the
horizontal direction but it's opposite
from the sign so if this was like x
minus pi it would actually shift it
right pi if it was x plus pi it would
actually shift it left pi to the to the
negative to the left pi
and the k value is what's shifting it up
and down that's the vertical shift if
it's plus two it'd go up two minus two
down two that one has the same effect on
the graph as the sine but the one group
of the x has the opposite effect so
that's an overview of you know the sine
and cosine graphs let's get into some
example problems see if you can solve
these on your own and we'll go through
them so the first one says what is the
amplitude of the sine graph y equals 3
sine 2x plus 4
well
you can see that this number in front of
the sign that's your amplitude so the
answer would just be three if they ask
you for the period the period would be
two pi divided by two which is just pi
if they ask you for the horizontal or
vertical shift this one's just shifting
up four so it'd be a vertical shift up
four so that's just kind of knowing the
you know the layout the format of the
equation there the second example they
give us a graph and it says what is the
period of the sinusoidal graph shown
okay so see if you can do this one you
can see they're giving us a few choices
a b c d
okay so the way i would do this is i
would look at you know how long does it
take for it to complete one cycle so you
can see it's going up
down
and back up so from zero
to four pi that's how long it took for
it to complete one cycle or repetition
so the period here is going to be four
pi letter d
you don't have to measure from here to
here you can measure from the peak to
the peak that's a good way to do it or
from the low point to the low point
that's a good way to do it you can see 7
pi minus 3 pi is giving you a period of
4 pi so more than one way to do that
in this case you can see the amplitude
is actually three so you're measuring
from this midline okay halfway so that
that's the height of the waves it's like
if you were standing on the the beach
here that's how high the waves are not
from here to here it's the max minus the
min divided by two
and the amplitude is always positive
so that's a quick review of working with
sine and cosine graphs i'll see in the
next lesson